hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna do a
general video about the importance of
prophecy and the song and Ice and Fire
novels that the TV show Game of Thrones
is based on I have plans to make videos
that look into individual prophecies in
the coming months while Game of Thrones
is on break so I wanted to make this
first as a primer it will contain
spoilers for everything related to the
Game of Thrones show through season six
and A Song of Ice and Fire books through
Dance with Dragons but that said it's
more food for thought about a way to
think about prophecy then it gives away
big plot points spoiler so prophecy is a
word that by definition means a
statement that something will happen in
the future it can also mean something
specifically tied to a prophet which in
this case would mean something will
happen because it is the will of a
divinity common theme with prophecy is
that it is somewhat vague and open for
interpretation it's a statement that
something will happen in the future but
the exact date time persons involved and
so on aren't exactly known if the
prophecy is related to divine will and
happens to be specific and doesn't come
true there is always wiggle room to say
that the fault lies with the interpreter
or prophet rather than the actual
divinity for a real world example of
this when I was a teenager I used to go
downtown to hang around a record store
in the summertime especially I went
there several times a week it wasn't a
big busy urban place with lots of foot
traffic and at one of the street corners
there was a woman who would show up and
warn everyone that they needed to go
inside their homes for three days my
friends and I called her the three days
lady because that's what she basically
always said three days three days her
prophecy warned that everyone needed to
go home and stay there to repent and get
right with God before the coming
judgement day her prophecy never changed
every day the world was three days away
from ending so to speak she was there
for years and may still do it now for
all that I know but I bring it up to
point out that if you happen to be
someone who encountered her for the
first time three days before an actual
apocalyptic event you might spend the
moment right before your destruction
believing that her prophecy had come
true when I first started reading the
books my thoughts on the prophecy I came
across were that it was just a
distraction and I didn't think any of
the ones we learned would come true this
was backed up by one of the first ones
we hear that Daenerys is unborn son Rago
would turn out to be the stallion that
mounts the world it's a prophecy that is
quickly disproven when Danny
Griese to a blood magic ritual with miry
mazdoor after which Rago dies in the
womb being somewhat cynical by nature
this was all the evidence I needed to
say that prophecy was nothing more than
a sideshow I mean I couldn't dispute
that this world was different than ours
since magic exists not long after the
stallion that mounts the world theory is
discredited Danny walks into her
husband's funeral pyre the one that she
happened to time marry mazdoor - and
where Miriam as Dora is actually burning
alive and where she also placed her
three dragon at the end
Daenerys emerges unburned with three
newly hatched dragons which is a feat
that no one has really been able to do
for like over 150 years she hatched
dragon that's pretty magical and if that
isn't enough think about the shadow baby
Melisandre conjured up this wasn't an
illusion or a trick she literally gave
birth to a shadow that existed in the
world long enough to go over and kill
Renly Baratheon
magic exists in this world and it can't
really be explained away this led to my
point of view being something like okay
this is a world like ours but it also
has magic which is a kind of extra
dimension or force of nature I figured
that all these religions that have
sprung up were similar to the ones in
our world they are there to offer
answers to people who live in a world
where a lot of things happen that just
don't make sense
and this would just then extend to
magical stuff as well
I was happy looking at it this way and
while I still found it interesting to
look at the prophecies I didn't think
any of them were included because they
would eventually be fulfilled over time
I ran into a problem with Melisandre and
I think she is the best example we can
use to understand what the importance of
these prophecies really is Melisandre is
a red priestess who follows the religion
of her lore who is the Lord of Light she
has visions while staring into flames
and she is famous for misinterpreting me
the problem is that pretty much
everything she sees actually comes true
in the stories so she has access to
something and even though she isn't
always spot-on about the details the
visions she has access to are prophetic
hers isn't the only case where this is
true but I use her for the example
because she's a well-known care you
could also look at the ghost of high
heart Maggy the Frog or jochen's green
dreams for similar evidence for a
specific event that we all remember
let's look at Melisandre and Stannis
burning the leeches the details are
slightly different but we see this in
the book and on in the show Melisandre
says she needs King's blood so she gets
some by leaching one of Roberts
faster the leeches are tossed into the
flames with the intent of causing Baylin
greyjoy Joffrey Baratheon and Robb Stark
to all die all of these things come true
which leads Stannis to believe then that
not only can Melisandre see the future
but she can also perform magic that can
lead to him getting things that he wants
to happen what's interesting about this
example is that as readers or viewers we
have much more information than Stannis
does we know that all those events would
have happened anyways and that
Melisandre didn't actually cause them to
happen at all what's more likely is that
the power we know she has being able to
see things that will happen in the
future
led her to already know about these
deaths and that they were going to
happen this put her in a position to
control Stannis by setting up the
burning knowing that his wishes would
come true so this all leads me the two
conclusions related to prophecy in A
Song of Ice and Fire in a game of throne
the first is that more often than not
prophecy is real and while it will
likely be misinterpreted by everyone
involved the underlying events will come
to pass basically it's there for a
reason and it shouldn't be discounted a
quick example of this is Maggy the Frog
telling Cersei her future the things
that she told her have also far come
true and no one else besides her knows
about the prophecy but she has been
letting it guide her decision-making
process all along the second conclusion
is that the real importance of prophecy
in this world is just that well it's
likely to come true without a doubt it
will shape major events and the way
major characters stories develop you
don't have to look further than Robert's
rebellion for evidence of this Rhaegar
Targaryen was obsessed with the prince
that was promised prophecy and it led
him to run off with Lyanna stark this
action led to the realm going to war and
the Targaryen is ultimately losing the
Iron Throne in the end it doesn't matter
if the prophecy is fulfilled what
matters is that Rhaegar believed in it
to the point of making decisions that
change things forever Danice does this
through Melisandre Cersei does this
through the Maggie prophecy and Daenerys
does this in relation to Quaithe and her
house of the undying experience even if
you disagree with my conclusions I think
you'll be able to agree that prophecy is
important and not to mention fun and
interesting to deconstruct I mean people
are always coming up with compelling new
theories based on the open-ended nature
of it all we get to get it wrong just
like the characters and the books get it
wrong and it's just really like a
win-win anyways I hope this gives you
something to think
about and I hope you leave a comment and
let me know what you think do you think
that like say the Izola Ohio Theory's
going to come true or do you think it
doesn't matter because it's really going
to shape the end of the series either
way as mentioned I'll be adding regular
prophecy videos over time so subscribe
to my channel and join the conversation
I also have a giveaway going on for when
I hit 18,000 subscribers I'm giving away
a copy of a night of the Seven Kingdoms
and all you have to do is be a
subscriber and leave a comment in the
video so let me know what your favorite
prophecy is or if you think prophecies
all bull or who do you think is over hi
is whatever just leave a comment and
you'll have a chance to win so thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon